do you feel like
um for you
when you put an album out in 2023 right
you're working on an album are you
paying attention to what's hot right now
are you just doing Mac 10. I'm doing Mac
10 which is smart because this [__] is
fun to me yeah you feel me uh if it
ain't fun I don't even want to do it
like this this is literally Kevin I'm
really just having fun and I'm doing Mac
10 like when you listen to King of
Chevys that don't sound like I listen to
whoever out now and say okay this is
what they doing now that's what I'm
gonna do [__] all that I'm a real one I
mean I do me I think that's smart too
because most artists they get away from
like yo this reason why people love you
yeah if you accepted me like this
I would I would be like a piece of [__]
to give you something different right
why you you didn't that ain't what you
ordered yeah I'm saying that's crazy
yeah so for you do you listen to the new
[__] like are you listening to like
little baby are you listening hell yeah
he's hard he hard as [__] yeah [__]
could rap for sure yeah he cold he cold
I listen to the new [__] but I'm still
me yep
I can't do number be me bro I'm good at
being me yeah you feel me and so you're
gonna get the best of me if I'm if I'm
me I don't care what nobody else is
doing I've been a trendsetter in a in a
a leader my whole life can you feel me
so so so you know I really don't give a
[__] what other people doing I kind of
just do me and just respect everybody
and what they doing that's fair any of
the young La guys that you're you're a
fan of that you're checking all of the
little youngsters now they like like I
like them little dudes you know I like
YG I like mustard you know my little son
district is cold as [__]
um
um um uh [__] Ty Dollar like like all
all I mean everybody really all the
little dudes is doing it right now in
this daytime like I'm proud of them
dudes because because I know how that is
you know what I'm saying that's a good
situation